in the book you talk about being a
prankster were you really a prankster as
a younger man yeah oh yeah I did a lot
of stuff growing up but then I had a
roommate who's very funny too and a
manager and we were living in the
Hollywood Hills right after the
Northridge earthquake which is a big
quake yeah yeah so we would play pranks
on people because we figured out that if
you went to our second floor if people
were in our living room on our third
floor we could shake our windows me and
my roommate had rooms next to each other
and if we shook the the windows really
hard it would shake the whole floor and
it felt like an earthquake so anyone
who's on the third floor you know dave
chappelle was over one day the day he
did that guy from comedy yeah yeah is 25
years ago or whatever and so we're
sitting in our living room and probably
playing video games maybe getting high
yeah definitely talking about how he was
gonna be the biggest comedy star ever
yeah and so he's talking about the
earthquake and how he's from the East
Coast in E or Midwest but lives in the
East Coast and was terrified by them and
hated all the aftershocks and everything
so me and my roommate gave each other
the signal and we went downstairs and
[ __ ] out of that house and we go
upstairs and Dave's gone gone he went to
the airport
[Laughter]
ran by down our stairs we didn't even
see him yeah yeah yeah I haven't seen
him in 25 good time to apologize sorry
kids probably the reason he still lives
in the Midwest he's never coming he's
never come back
good going Brian good going
you